Hello. This is 6 Minute English
from BBC Learning English.
I'm Neil...
and I'm Beth.
Now, imagine
a field polluted by spilled oil.
Toxic waste has mixed
into the water and chemical fumes
have overtaken the air, leaving animals
dead and the land unsafe for humans.
Unfortunately, situations like this
are common all over the world.
Cleaning up chemical pollution
is dangerous and expensive
and mostly involves
highly technological equipment.
But what if there was
a more natural solution?
Recently, scientists
have been developing a new technique
for cleaning pollution,
letting plants do the work instead.
Yes, plants like water hyacinths
have been used to clean rivers by
sucking up oil spilled into the water.
And researchers
have successfully used fungi
to break down plastic waste.
In this programme,
we'll be hearing about plants
that fight pollution and of course,
we'll be learning
some useful new vocabulary as well.
But first, I have a question for you, Neil.
One word we'll be hearing a lot in this
programme is ‘phytoremediation’ -
the technique that certain plants
use to remove harmful chemicals
from polluted environments.
But how do they do this? Is it by using
a) their leaves, b) their roots,
or c) their seeds?
I think some plants clean up
pollution using their roots.
OK, Neil. We'll find out
the correct answer later.
Phytoremediating plants
are certainly needed
in one of the most
oil-polluted places on Earth.
The delta of the River Niger
in Nigeria.
Ever since oil,
known by the nickname
'black gold' was discovered there
in the 1950s,
it's become central
to Nigeria's economy.
But oil spills have devastated
the region's landscape
and there is mistrust
between local communities
and the multinational oil companies
working there.
Now, one woman and her plants are
trying to fix the problem. Eucharia Nwaichi
is a biochemist
from the University of Port Harcourt
in Nigeria,
She uses phytoremediation to clean
and protect the region's land and
rivers. Discussing Eucharia’s work,
are Georgina Rannard
from the BBC Climate
news team and Myra Anubi,
presenter of BBC
World Service Programme,
People Fixing the World.
Eucharia is a specialist in
phytoremediation…
... that word again.
It basically means plants being used
to clean up contaminated environment, right?
Right.
When I met her recently in London,
she had just won the Maddox prize.
This is a prestigious award
for scientists showing courage
in the face of hostility.
Now, the Niger Delta is a really dangerous
and challenging place to work in and
despite personal risk to her safety,
Eucharia has spent 20 years
teaching communities there,
how these plants
can suck up toxic oil from the ground
and bring their land back to life.
Eucharia's work won a prestigious
scientific award. 'Prestigious' means
admired and well respected.
The award recognised the personal risks
Kari or takes in her efforts
to bring the land back to life.
If you bring something back to life.
You make it come alive again
or re animate it after it has died
a big problem for climate scientists
is being accepted and trusted by
the people living in polluted places,
but Eucharia has found
a way to work with local communities.
Listen to Georgina Rannard of BBC
World Service's People Fixing the World,
who was followed by
Eucharia Nwaichi herself...
Her success, often comes
from getting communities
who have deep mistrust of outsiders
after broken promises from companies
to clean up the oil spills.
She gets them to trust her
and then they take ownership
for the restoration of their land.
And I think Eucharia's magic formula
really relies on diplomacy,
trust and actually charisma,
which is a very important quality.
We have a leadership structure,
so you have the chief, like
traditional ruler.
You have the women leader.
You have the youth leader.
So, you find out who does
and inform them of
what you want to do.
Local people's mistrust of big oil companies
comes from their broken promises.
when they said
they would definitely do something.
but then failed to.
Eucharia, on the other hand,
is trusted because she consults the
community by speaking with local chiefs -
the rulers or highest ranking leaders
of the tribe.
What's more, Eucharia
has lots of 'charisma'.
This personal characteristic is the
natural ability to attract, influence
and inspire people.
Taken together,
these make Eucharia's approach
a magic formula -
a combination of actions
that is likely to result in success.
It's good to hear a positive environmental
news story for once, isn't it, Neil?
But what's the science behind
what Eucharia is doing?
How do plants clean up polluted
environments? To find that out
I need to reveal the answer
to my question.
Right, you asked me how plants
clean up pollution through phytoremediation.
I said it was using their roots.
And that was the correct answer.
OK, it's time to recap vocabulary
we've learnt from the programme,
starting with the adjective 'prestigious'
meaning admired and well respected.
If you 'bring something back to life'.
you make it come alive again
after being dead.
A 'broken promise' is when you promise
definitely to do something
but then fail to do
what you said you would.
A 'chief' is the ruler of a tribe
or the most important highest
ranking leader of an organisation.
'Charisma' is a special natural ability
to attract, influence and inspire people.
And finally, the phrase 'a magic formula'
describes a combination of actions
that is likely to result in success.
Once again, our six minutes are up.
Bye for now.
Goodbye.